schon seit anfang juni ist der mars
rover opportunity der nasa sturm werden
darüber berichtet ein gewaltiger
staubsturm war bei den roten planeten
geprägt und hatte den rover damit daran
gehindert seine batterien wieder
aufzuladen und daran hat sich nichts
geändert die nasa ist besorgt und hat
jetzt einen plan aufgestellt wie es mit
ihrem mars-rover weitergehen wie
kritisch die lage möglich ist jetzt bei
klicks und science fiction herzlich
willkommen der standort ist klar viel
mehr aber auch nicht der mars rover
opportunity verharrt auf dem roten
planeten an einer stelle namen space
marines valley
doch er meldet sich nicht zurück und das
schon seit dem 10 juni 2018
ja jetzt versucht es das nasa
forschungsteam offensichtlich mit allen
mitteln so heißt es dass jeden morgen
passende aufwacht lieder gespielt werden
wie etwa here comes the sun von den
beatles denn wie der zustand des rovers
hat wirklich ist bleibt weiter unter und
der song wird quasi als signal genutzt
um dann eine antwort vom nova zu
bekommen doch das forschungsteam hofft
weiter darauf dass sich der oper wegen
des fehlenden sonnenlicht selbst
ausgeschaltet hat die nasa selbst
bezeichnet die lage als kritisch dennoch
sei man vorsichtig optimistisch
schließlich habe opportunity schon viele
kritische situationen und
herausforderungen gemeistert und das
waren in seinen 14 jahren auf dem mars
so einige
dennoch steht auch fest der rover hat
bereits jetzt 60 mal länger als
eigentlich geplant auf dem roten
planeten ausgehalten denn ursprünglich
war seine mission auf 90 tage ausgelegt
seine garantie frist ist also schon
längst verstrichen sein zwillings rover
spirit war mit ihm im jahr 2004 auf dem
mars gelandet und hatte ebenfalls den
eigentlichen plan weit übertroffen er
hatte 20 mal länger auf dem mars
ausgehalten als ursprünglich vorgesehen
dazu einer der beteiligten nasa
projektmanager john callas wir hoffen
dass unser bei herrlicher rover seine
füße noch einmal aus dem feuer ziehen
kann wenn er es schafft werden wir da
sein und ihn hören und das dürfte
eigentlich nicht mehr also lange dauern
falls die funkstille tatsächlich an dem
staubsturm liegt denn der hat
nachgelassen und der dunst um
opportunity lichtet sich so langsam
lehrplan der nasa jedenfalls ist
ausgetüftelt erst wenn das so genannte
travel
1,5 fällt werden die experten wieder mit
einer aktiven kontaktaufnahme staaten
das travel ist eine einheit mit der sich
die anzahl der staubpartikel in der
marsatmosphäre messen lässt das
sogenannte deep space network der nasa
soll dann kommandos zum mars schicken
und hören was dabei herumkommt wenn
opportunity antwortet soll laut des zwei
stufen plans sein status ermittelt
werden und der rover dann
schnellstmöglich wieder online gebracht
werden es gibt aber auch noch ein
zweites mögliches szenario
wie sieht es für opportunity alles
andere als gut aus denn die nasa kann
nicht ausschließen dass die
empfindlichen geräte des rovers durch
die massive kälte auf dem mars gestört
worden sind und die funk stelle stelle
daher rührt dazu colours wenn wir nach
45 tagen keine reaktion des rovers
bekommen wird das team gezwungen sei
davon auszugehen dass der rover sich
nicht mehr erholen wird wir werden in
diesem fall aber mehrere monate lang
weiter passiv nach opportunity lauschen
selbst dann bei einer solchen passiven
suche nach signalen gibt es nach angaben
der nasa aber noch hoffnung der grund
ein phänomen das man 2004 sowohl bei
spirit als auch bei opportunity
beobachtet hatte
damals waren die energie level der rover
über nacht um mehrere prozent
angestiegen und das obwohl sie nachts
hätten eigentlich ab fallen sollen doch
das rätsel konnte gelüftet werden eine
staub hose also vom wind aufgewirbelte
staub hatte die solarpaneele gesäubert
genau das könnte natürlich auch im
besten fall jetzt wieder passiert falls
opportunity dagegen für immer verstummt
sein sollte kann die nasa sicher noch
mit goya city trösten denn dieser rover
ist nicht von sonnenenergie abhängig
zudem soll die ende november ein
weiterer länder auf dem mars ankommen
sein name inside seine mission das
innere des mars erforschen und jetzt
clixoom wird werbefrei keine triumph
mehr mit eurer hilfe
immer wenn wir entsprechend viele kanal
mitglieder gewonnen haben schalten wir
die werbung vor jeweils einem video im
monat ab bald ist es beim ersten video
soweit werdet also mit liegt hier unter
dem video drauf kriegen und bekommt noch
exklusive extra videos exklusive live
streams wie am kommenden dienstag und
noch ein paar weitere
wir legen ein riesen dank an all
diejenigen die schon dabei sind das ist
wirklich absolut fantastisch ja es
werden immer mehr und wenn ihr immer
garantiert über aktuelle videos
informiert werden wollt dann hättet mich
übrigens bei whatsapp dann bekommt er
den link zum video vor allen anderen von
mir persönlich auf euer handy einfach
hier draufklicken und hier geht es
weiter mit dafür auch dort blicken 1000
raketen zum mars bis dann bleibt dran